hyundai est aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur potash traction sur des maps mach le
principe est hyper simple en gros tu es
sur des plateformes qui tiennent sur des
piliers et la demande qui balancent des
morceaux de terre avec des canons sur
les plates formes et sur les piliers de
sorte à ce que le patron se pète la
gueule et dès que tu tombes tu es mort
bon visionnage
oh merci les mecs on peut jouer sinon
aussi merci d'avancé [ __ ] attends
attends je remet juste leçon de jeu est
en attente inquiète inquiète matt
hackett le maître et l'on voit un groupe
je suis je peux voir m qu'est ce que
vous allez faire
j'ai vu que ma tête allez les mecs je ne
bouge plus voilà donc un message vidéo
parce que je pense
je suis un pro je suis accro aux poteaux
et donc nous plaît j'ai couru dans le
vide au liban j'essaie de faire mon gars
tu penses quoi
non ce coup c'est un petit temps des
champions et hop voilà sont bloqués dans
les bus
sans ce jeu est trop sale or ce pourri
dégage déjà voilà on voit très bien le
mec 14
j'ai pas envie j'assiste n'aurait pas
envie j'insiste au nez dans les bras
tu t'es pris acte et sortie du porte à
porte c'est la même interdiction
j'attends des jeunes allaient tomber
tétouan les tricheurs mon gars
là on n'est jamais symbole typ o alors
j'explique ma ce qui regarde cette vidéo
en fait là c'est plus de mecs qui nous
tire dessus avec des cadeaux mais c'est
automatique voit des trucs qui volent
équipe est ou non
cap à droite a pas droit d'entrée dans
les deux cas je vous laisse hélas les
bus et ont demandé les gardes du corps
baker n'abandonne pas le lieu de travail
vous abandonnez pas si mecha sa voisine
plus nécessaire dans le bus les murs les
sols et bien on est gâté d'être écrasés
à 1 min 22 mois seulement
michael e on attendait
sas avec l'oculus truste le cumul strict
pendant tu détestes tut tut décède
ok je parle d'un budget d'une phase est
maintenant à voir ce que je voulais dire
quoi non non on peut compter autour des
majorettes à la clé mais jack c'est pour
nous les mecs vous aimez compteront pour
le contre pour nous tu racontais mes
canons j'en ai par dessus ses grands
jours et dans mon nom il est passé allez
tout cela peut-être les enfants
regardent et bien ça c'est le trou de
l'himalaya non on ne panique pas gardez
votre calme s'il vous plaît à tanger
comme un gentil curité dans un
intermarché souple et gamal calmes
on s'arrêtera du cac on savait pas à
quoi je voulais pas rater ma route je
touche la situation à l'appareil non tu
n'as pas ton plus grand tueur est sur la
tombe us enfin black blocs et moi look
est brave alesi bloquer quoi tu fais
alors mortes ou de transition
oro qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est la
grande finale là la grande finale et à
regarder chez hp crash
ça m'apprendra à vouloir tricher voilà
j'espère que cette petite vidéo sur
l'image de counter strike source vous
aura plu ces cas n'hésitez pas mais la
vidéo ça me fera pas plaisir on se
retrouve très bientôt dans de nouvelles
chorégraphies petite vidéo que tout le
monde a peace
c'est
et
m